they say you can't judge a book by its
cover but you can judge a person by his
Twitter bio we will take a look at
Twitter bios they're not they're not
Twitter bios anymore they're ex bios
some people don't know how to interpret
liberal leads they don't know what the
meaning is in these bios so I am going
to give you really quick rules of thumb
that will get past that first layer that
facade into what the person really is by
their Twitter bio take it away if Taylor
Simpson Ukrainian flag it would be at
this point I would move past this
Twitter but I would say there's no
reason to listen to what this person has
to say I don't even need to see the rest
of it I will for explanatory purposes
here but that Ukraine flag emoji that is
sufficient to say move along Taylor
Simpson Ukraine flag
some other flag my eyes aren't great is
that a is that a shark what is on that
it's a map that's fitting because most
people couldn't identify Ukraine on a
map especially the most belligerently
Pro Ukraine war people the handle is the
beagle and he is an anarcho Progressive
anti-fascist communist
start there the more descriptors
the less valuable the opinion will be
you often see this on the right this is
not just a lib thing I've heard obscure
political moniker is referred to as the
right-wing version of gender pronouns
and so the lives do this sometimes to a
narco Progressive anti-fascist communist
grow-up man you're a big lib okay
followed by she they sometimes this
person is one person sometimes this
person is multiple people Legion for
their many gen Xin impact I don't know
what that means
dude
I'm actually at a loss I usually can use
semantic Clues to figure out what's
going on here I have no idea engine
impact is a free-to-play action
adventure game with RPG elements uh
furry curious
Ukraine is that a Muslim flag and then
three shots that's great I assume this
has got to be a parody account I assume
this has to be a conservative who set
this up are you sure about that but in
the world that we live today in the
world that we live in I sound like Paul
McCartney and Live and Let Die this
ever-changing world in which we live in
[Applause]
in this world of ours today I don't know
I'm not positive maybe you really could
be a pro-ukraine
again she ain't very curious vaxxed
person next one soy loving beta male he
her these are Zim I'm Cody pronouns
emsers white transmasculine Femme
non-binary temporarily mostly
able-bodied neurodivergent
obsessive-compulsive chronically ill
culturally Jewish Unitarian Universalist
non-monogamous Demi lo-romantic gray
demibosexual Survivor of acute and
complex trauma Millennial and Cat parent
in mental health recovery
okay I see the Ukraine flag
sjw13612 okay so now I know this is a
fake account and I know this is a fake
account because no sjw really calls
himself an sjw and frankly that term is
kind of 2015 energy you're the social
justice Warrior now they just call
themselves I don't know like demons or
something like that the sjws kind of
dated a global citizen Progressive vegan
climate activist power bottom
I believe that's a gay
sex term my wife Fawn and I are the
proud parents of two adorable fur babies
than gay then I don't know what what's
that second mask
oh is that is that two guys or something
two dudes kissing I need glasses to
do this exercise next time okay so this
is obviously a parody account that very
accurately expresses the views of
sincere Ernest Libs next one facts
boosted times two still a coveted virgin
Smiley Ukraine the Ukraine is kind of
the giveaway a retired now with
experience in nursing philosophy and
academic theology former Roman Catholic
now melkite Byzantine liturgy if you're
a melkite aren't you still Catholic
There Is No Escape they just have a
different liturgy as you say in some
different ecclesiological rules but
they're basically part of the church I
thought nursing philosophy academic
theology this might be a real person I
assume it's a fake facts boost at times
two still a covid virgin that's well
that's how I know it's a fake account
because every person who got the vaccine
got covered like a thousand times so
that's the okay that's the giveaway I
think I figured it out next one backs
three times boostered facts plus wearing
masks and crowds old female German
living in Germany ex-american Army
spouse resist vote blue or the U.S will
turn into Gilead no DMS no crypto no
Maga so this is a fake account too he's
a phony a great big phone these are just
too far right now go to genucel.com
Knowles YT our friends over at geniusell
sold out of their dark spot corrector
and our listeners have been begging
begging like dogs for a restock well
I've got great news just in time for the
summer it's back in stock Jamie sells
famous Dark Spot Corrector has not won
but three Cutting Edge ingredients in
goes to work fast to Target sunspots
dark spots liver spots even all
discoloration both on your face and
hands you can now enjoy your summer sun
Beach and barbecues without embarrassing
spots geniuselle's most popular package
also features their summer Essentials
such as the best-selling Ultra retinol
moisturizer with a powerful retinol
alternative for safe use in the sun see
results very quickly or 100 of your
money back guaranteed go to
jnsl.comt right now to get your dark
spot corrector in the geniusell most
popular package that is geniusell.com
Knowles YT right now save over 77 zero
percent off jnsl's most popular package
all orders include a mystery luxury gift
while supplies last geniusell.com
Knowles y t Dr Elizabeth coster's four
times vaxxed two Ukraine black emojis uh
scientists living on a hyper tidal minus
base and look it up
Oma I assume stroke survivor Gardener
born at 312 parts per million she her
Anonymous tweets are ignored from
esoquatic meek Maki Canada yeah I kind
of lean that this
kind of lean that this one's fake too I
remember one time I was working on a
political campaign and I was trying to
infiltrate the opponent political
campaign and I made up an email address
and a kind of identity to do it and they
didn't respond to me because it was too
on the nose and I think these are a
little too on the nose whether they're
being put up as a just a parody account
like buying a non on the right which
could be or buy these lib activist
organizations that spam conservatives
whenever there's a cancel call put out
on us they're a little too on the nose
Santiago Correa he him gay four times
faxed assistant professor at Columbia
BME postdoc at Apple group in Stanford
PhD Hammond lab MIT b-sel
self-assembling nanotechnologies for
immuno engineering
some flag from Columbia this one I think
could be real he is real he's really
really real he looks like virtually
every single person I ever met at Yale
so I kind of believe that he isn't a he
they there it's a he him and he's gay so
so far this is all checking out oh it's
a Colombian flag and he's an assistant
professor Colombia so I think that one's
that one checks out to me and that would
probably not be an account that I would
follow April four times vaxed still no
5G damn it Ukraine mom Metal Head mental
health therapist M Ed LPC resist
vaccinated BLM science offended by
racism and misogyny not swearing no DMS
that might be real that might be real
and this uh I'm not offended by swearing
thing this is a real marker of a lib
they're all the same Mike especially
when it comes to women because it's
wrong to use naughty language generally
but especially in front of women maybe
you go out to the bar you talk a little
bit like a sailor foreign
Mixed Company it's very wrong to do that
it gives offense and it diminishes you
as a man liberals because they want to
upend everything that's normal and good
and true they try to flip all this stuff
so the the women will often have a
nastier mouth than even the men and
they'll make a big point of this this is
like left-wing comedians you know female
comedians such as they are they'll their
whole Act is they'll just say disgusting
things they'll say I'm not offended by
naughty words well you should be they're
offensive if you're not offended by
offensive things something's going wrong
with you you're a lady you gotta act
like a lady you go with all your vaxes
and no 5G I think there's a fair shot
that's a real one okay who's my favorite
one
the guy that I'm most convinced is where
I'm still not 100 convinced he's real
but yeah I'm most convinced it's real
that Colombia Stanford Yale gay
Colombian
unneuro science with 25 vaccines or
something that he's my favorite one
because his was the most believable are
you believable am I real more on that
next time see you then
[Music]